ma mère a fait trois choses pour moi
une
entrer elle m'a épargné le jour de ma
naissance
non je ne le ferai pas
deux
elle a payé mon entretien à genoux et
sur son dos m'embrasser pourquoi pour
célébrer ma méchanceté
et trois
elle m'a donné l'histoire que je ne pourrais jamais dire
si elle vivait
avec un secret
que feriez-vous il y a un code que
nous avons survécu à
l'histoire écrite d'ellen
dans son histoire elle dit qu'elle vit
avec des vampires
ma mère vit de sang humain
et a fait pour deux  des siècles
elle est une aberration
nous sommes une fraternité il n'y a pas de femmes
parmi nous
nous ne devrions pas être autorisés à survivre
volons-nous du temps nous l'achetons
avec du sang
nous avons déjà été ici
où est-elle
seuls ceux qui sont prêts à mourir trouveront
la vie éternelle